ja nun ist es traurige Gewissheit der
seit drei Wochen in einem schweren
Schneesturm vermisste Bergsteiger Julian
P aus Hannover ist tot die Besatzung
eines österreichischen
Polizeihubschraubers entdeckte die
Leiche des 24-Jährigen am Hochkalter in
den Berchtesgadener Alpen Julian P hatte
am 17 Dezember September noch ein Notruf
abgesetzt weil er während eines
Schneesturms abgerutscht war und sich
verletzt hatte und nach mehreren
Telefonaten ristern aber der Kontakt
dauerhaft ab und besonders tragisch sein
Leiche die wurde ganz in der Nähe an der
Stelle gefunden an der auch zuvor seinen
Rucksack gefunden worden war
[Musik]